fit healthy and unwilling to be
vaccinated
that describes a minority of young
britons keen to get on with normal life
after the lifting of most lockdown
restrictions
no thank you i think it would be no
thank you i think that um
you know we shouldn't be forced to have
something or take something
when you know if i've had people like
tara knowles
so having a vaccine and putting these
extra things in my body that
they're currently not even sure of we're
kind of
the guinea pigs right now the problem is
that current infection rates are highest
among young people
with medics warning that hospital
patients are getting younger
and younger they describe it as
heartbreaking to watch the unvaccinated
suffer
unnecessarily the other thing that
people should take into account is that
if they are not vaccinated then they're
more likely to spread it to other people
perhaps vulnerable relatives that they
come in contact with
but also i think a responsibility to
society
not to be spreading this around because
it will encourage the emergence of
variants which are
uh able to escape from the vaccine and
that will simply put everybody back into
lockdown again
nobody wants to do that official figures
suggest up to 10 percent of under 30s
are reluctant or simply refuse to be
vaccinated
with almost 3 million young adults yet
to receive a first dose
that's led to a dramatic slowdown in the
overall vaccine rollout
leaving a potentially dangerous back
door open to the virus
and the possibility of new variants the
government has backed measures to
encourage vaccination including
discounts on food deliveries and taxi
rides
and this free vaccine music festival in
london
there are more controversial plans to
incentivize the jab by introducing
vaccine passports to access nightclubs
which human rights groups say is the
wrong approach
coercion does not make us safer it's
actually been
proven that countries that have
mandatory vaccine policies or coercive
vaccine policies
have a much lower trust in vaccines and
what we're talking about is totally
restructuring society
um creating a system of checkpoints um
massive violation of privacy locking
some people out of society
for a very very small number of people
is this really the way we want to go
about public health in this country i
don't think so
big brother watch says refusing the
vaccine is a basic
right which sets the wider goal of full
vaccine coverage
against the interests of those who
believe they're better off without it
jonah al jazeera london